somehow we're already in March and as
usual PlayStation Plus is offering some
free games for subscribers if you're one
of them and want to know what you can
grab in the new month I've got you
covered
first up on ps4 is Shadow of the
Colossus if you missed any of the games
re-releases you don't really have an
excuse to skip the cult classic now the
ps4 remake is a complete visual overhaul
but it's still the same story of a young
boy climbing and conquering massive
monsters known as the colossi 16 of them
to be exact in celebration of the new
Sonic movie ps4 s other free game is
sonic forces this particular Sonic game
serves up three different gameplay
styles you can run across classic
inspired to D levels - through more
modern 3d stages and even play as your
own custom character of course the usual
cast of hedgehogs echidnas and Eggman
robots are here too and those are your
free PS Plus games for March they'll be
available from March 3rd through April
6th remember that you can always check
out gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles on GameSpot in stay tuned as we
report on the new PS Plus lineup every
month
[Music]